what's going on there citizens of the reject
Nation Greg here today I was out of town because
this guy was gives himself a little hitched
yes yes and this trailer actually came out
at the time of the ceremony so of course I
could not cover it but after an 18-hour road
trip I'm playing a little bit of catch up here
and I want her to watch the open Heimer trailer
I have become death the destroyer of worlds I
know a little bit about Oppenheimer like kind
of the the general information the Manhattan
Project nuclear bombs all that fun stuff but
I'm excited that Christopher Rollins take on
this role I hear Killian Murphy Chilean Murphy
Cillian Murphy everyone has a different
pronunciation for it comment below what
the correct pronunciation is for it because I can
never seem to remember I think uh he's actually a
wonderful person to cast as Oppenheimer actually
so I'm excited for this man everything about it
sounds great John he is in Colorado for a
little while longer enjoying himself and
you know the rest of the team mainly the rest
of the team meeting koi is uh he's got himself
in ear infection so just me right now but hey
let's get to it guys I'd also leave a like that
would be very much a pretty leave a like you
know how much I love it when you leave a like
whoa
wow
we imagine a future
and our imaginings horrifiers
they won't fear it
until they understand it
they won't fear it until they
understand it they won't understand it
until they've used it
Theory will take you only so
far dare Happy Looks tortured
I don't know if we can be
trusted with such a weapon
that look he has in his eyes man
there's that classic Christopher Nolan text
Queen
ever
trying to tell the truth
about what's Happening Here
God damn music is so the music you know in the
films so solid you know I really what really
struck me about performance of Killian Murphy
here silly Murphy children for whatever I did
remember hearing that Oppenheimer was diagnosed
with schizophrenia and he refused to believe uh
that diagnosis like succumb to that but you know
knowing how I know some people have different
interpretations about after he created the nuclear
bomb and of course that famous quote of for he is
quoting I have become death to destroyer of worlds
the general takeaway from that was that after he
created it he was immediately filled with that
feeling of remorse uh regret over what he has
done it's almost like he's like the real-life
Frankenstein to a certain extent dedicates his
whole life for years to developing this then
once he succeeds and then when they they run
the test I believe was it in New Mexico when
they when they ran the test and you could see
like oh my god what have I created I've created
the ultimate Destroyer the Ultimate Weapon and I
bring up the schizophrenia part of it because so
much of the performance seems to have that tense
paranoia just within his eyes alone that was so
striking and when you do see that footage that
that old footage of Oppenheimer yeah he did have
that like wide-eyed look and the the parts of this
trailer that I thought were really interesting
were what it does seem like the development of
the nuclear bomb the whole Manhattan Project time
which was quite a scrutinous experience you know
obviously heavily heavily secretive there's also
just constant surveillance on the guy just it's no
no it's complete surrender of privacy you even
capture some of that with with the amount of
just like all eyes on me and what am I doing and
is this the right voice and what I find really
fascinating about experiencing just the trailer
alone is while there's that horror clearly that
haunting quality of this creation that did take
the lives of hundreds of thousands of people it
still had that the the build up of of the Journey
of develop because you know obviously it doesn't
strike me as that Oppenheimer was someone who was
like this diabolical you know evil guy genius dude
who is instantly like yeah I want to do this
to kill a bunch of people I want to do this
to destroy a bunch of lives you know it seemed
like to be capturing that while there's that
percolating Darkness it seemed to constantly have
this this sense of wonder as well that that Nolan
Wonder touch which is probably what Oppenheimer
had in the development of this or in the pursuit
and curiosity of discovering physics and all
all that it is all the life shears Journey
leading up to that moment of developing this
and being part of the Manhattan Project and I
thought that was all captured here in quite an
elegant way and there's something that feels
wondrous ethereal and nightmarish as your inner
cutting you know inner splicing all these all
these different moment of the flashes of the the
nuclear bomb like like the way it was at least
being demonstrated here felt like that was part of
how he's envisioning it like maybe this you know
no one's known to play with time so maybe this
won't play out in such a linear way because you
have moments that are in black and white in this
trailer I didn't see the first teaser for this I
did see there were some black and white images
I didn't see the teaser for this I wonder like
is it going to be dealing with cutting around
through time and and not in a non-linear way
of exploring how this all sort of came to being
developed yeah I mean I thought that was uh quite
a beautiful trailer it's Christopher Nolan's
first time not first big movie without Warner
Brothers this is the first picture with universal
so I'm excited to see what difference is if any
that would ultimately entail I like the classic
Nolan text he seems to constantly have that text
the part that has me a bit concerned a a bit is
I feel like Nolan's films are generally better
because he tends to be uh one of the writers at
least but but his Inception co-written by someone
I I generally have the association and I could
be wrong I'm not sure there's a fantastic null
in film that because I I either like or love
his films there's not about one of his movies
I straight up dislike but I I tend to feel his
films tend to hit a little stronger when he has
a co-writer with it so that's my one one time
and one little bit of a concern there is that
it's it's just him credited a soul Rider here so
other than that I mean this looks like a quite
a fascinating experience you know because he
did Dunkirk which was a historical piece this
is another historical biographical piece as well
as exploring a time in human history development
something this innovations that that have still
to this day like it's scary man it's some scary
stuff you know there are active projects or active
campaigns you can donate to uh that are all about
out you know to help put away like all nuclear
bombs and just that way it just doesn't exist like
it just shouldn't exist at all no one should even
have that as an option because of the disaster so
I wonder how violent It'll like will they show the
Horrors of like Hiroshima and stuff what will we
see some of that like how how much are we going
to actually show or is it all going to be solely
focused on The Haunting experience of Oppenheimer
Oppenheimer chilly and silly and Killian I thought
it was a great trailer though I thought I thought
it was excellent and you know like a Nolan film on
IMAX gets me so excited gets me so excited like
just the visual experiencer it's rare for me to
experience a Nolan film for the first time on on
IMAX because I I tend to be too late to buy the
tickets I do love the experience of first watching
it on a regular screen and then going to IMAX and
doing kind of a comparison in the IMAX tends to
just be so immersive and sweeping that's why I
understood for the first time on IMAX that was
great yeah this looks awesome awesome it feels
like that great Christopher Nolan touch and you
know like in terms of caption that paranoia the
guy did insomnia and Memento two films were
main characters had a constant paranoia and
uh I like it I like it a lot this looks awesome
guys what'd you think about the trailer leave your
thoughts down below be sure to subscribe leave
a like and uh hey I'll talk with you all soon
thank you